[Music]  imagine this thought experiment everyone  gathers in a great assembly to vote on  the principles that will govern society  but during the assembly everyone  temporarily forgets his or her social  and economic status you don't know your  race gender religion ethnicity or class  you don't know whether you were rich or  poor strong or weak healthy or unhealthy  under these conditions which of these  principles would you choose to govern  social and economic inequalities one  permit only those inequalities that  increase the overall welfare of society  or total utility to permit only those  inequalities that benefit the least  advantaged members of society or three  permit whatever inequalities result when  some people work hard and exercise their  talents more successfully than others  you